record fuel prices can make filling up
these days feel like robbery at pump
point so in the days of the 100-pound
tank are consumers getting a fair deal
government has asked regulators to
investigate and they found cause for
concern in parts of the market what we
found is there are two main factors
driving the prices up one is the
increase in global crude oil prices that
accounts for about a third of that
overall increase but the other big
factor and this is something that we're
particularly focused on now is that the
gap the difference between that crude
oil price and the wholesale cost of
petrol and diesel coming out of the
refineries that difference has actually
more than tripled over the last year and
that's something we really think is
essential to get to the bottom of that's
why today we're announcing a formal
market study to take our investigation
further
petrol and diesel prices have risen
around 60 pence a liter in a year the
cma found the increase in crude oil
prices and the falling value of the
pound contributed 27 pence
while the gap between the cost of crude
oil going into refineries and the
wholesale price of petrol and diesel
coming out was up 24 p
but the margin between wholesale and
retail prices was largely unchanged at
around 10 pence
the petroleum industry says it will
cooperate with the cma and that it
sympathizes with motorists some of whom
staged a go slow on motorways this week
in protest at soaring prices
drivers are long suffering from
particularly high prices at the pumps at
the moment and we don't feel those
prices are justified the wholesale price
of fuel that's the price which major
retailers buy the fuel in for has been
dropping weekly for weeks and weeks and
weeks now and yet retail pump prices
haven't changed to reflect that the cma
will also examine price differences
between outlets and has urged government
to make retailers share real-time price
information with motorists but many want
ministers to cut duty first
one thing government can do is cut taxes
and this investigation found that a five
percent vat reduction was passed on to
customers at the pumps but that still
leaves 45 of the price of a liter made
up of v80 and fuel duty and without
further big cuts there's not much chance
that prices will come down here anytime
soon
with up to a year before the cma reports
back it looks like a long expensive
summer on the road paul kelso sky news